im sinne der co2 neutralität wenn wir
die energieform die co2 113 die ganz
kurz und ganz schnell wir sind wieder
zurück geben im bundestag wo es einen
antrag der unionsfraktion geht zu
sichere und bezahlbare energieversorgung
zur begründung des antrags der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unionsfraktion jens spahn wir
unterstützen insoweit alle diese
bemühungen bei all dem darf die
bundesregierung keine falschen
vorstellungen verbinden wir brauchen
kurzfristige lösungen und putin frei zu
werden in unserer energieversorgung
vieles was wir aktuell debattieren trägt
aber höchstens mittel und langfristig
dazu bei und vor allem braucht es
entschlossenheit auch in der umsetzung
pipelines leitung terminals die bauen
sich eben nicht nur durch erklärungen
sondern wären wir jetzt vor allem die
regierungen auch mit nachdruck dran
bleibt ein letztes ein wichtiges thema
and und geschlossenheit filter koalition
ganz offensichtlich auch bei den hohen
energiepreisen deswegen vorab wir
begrüßen es dass die bundesregierung
nunmehr einige der forderungen die wir
hier vor einem monat erhoben haben auch
umsetzt damals haben sie noch alles
abgewehrt heute tun sie ist gut so aber
leider viel zu spät
wir begrüßen ist dass sie eine
regelrechte kehrtwende hier hinlegen
jetzt soll es angesichts der steigenden
spritpreise wieder finanzminister eine
entlastung noch ausgeschlossen hat vor
einer woche doch eine entlastung gehen
mindestens unter deutlich zwei euro das
hat er gesagt an dieser ankündigung
werden wir die bundesregierung messen
bevor die koalition eigene vorschläge
auf den tisch gelegt hat arbeitet sie
sich an unseren vorschlägen ab seit
tagen das ist okay aber zur wahrheit
gehört eben auch dass die wählerinnen
und wähler ihnen einen regierungsauftrag
gegeben haben und ich uns und deswegen
herr scholz der harbeck herr lindner
erwarten wir erwarten vor allem die
pendler die familien die lkw-fahrer all
diejenigen die jeden tag an der
zapfsäule zahlen müssen dass sie hier
endlich lösungen auf den tisch legen
dass wir zur entlastung die schnell
wirksam sind und einen unterschied
machen
die entlastung so schnell wir hätten
unbürokratisch sein und mindestens 40
cent pro liter ausmachen eine
tankfüllung kostet mittlerweile bei 50
litern 110 120 euro wie sollen wir das
alles noch bezahlen diese frage stellen
sich viele menschen im land und deswegen
bitte so schnell wie möglich denn das
wirkt auch sofort die mehrwertsteuer die
mineralöl- oder energie steuer auf den
sprit senken die sanktionen sollen putin
und seine oligarchen treffen und nicht
die pendler und deswegen braucht es hier
deutliche entlastung
wenn es dann heißt und wie schnell sie
können gern weiter sprechen das aber auf
kosten ihrer kollegen kommen ja auch
schon zum schluss frau präsidentin
vielen dank wenn es dann heißt das dass
in brüssel schwer wäre ja das mag sein
man muss sich dann in brüssel einsetzen
für dieses thema andere länder in europa
tun dass auch diese erwartung haben wir
auch an die bundesregierung und deswegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen brauchen
wir eine putin freie energieversorgung
dafür einen plan der bundesregierung wie
das gelingen soll wir brauchen eine
technologieoffene ideologiefreie prüfung
aller optionen aber vor allem haben es
die familien pendler verdient dass die
spritpreise endlich sinken tun sie was
und das sagt iren sparen der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unionsfraktion zum antrag aus der
unionsfraktion der sich beschäftigt mit
einer sicheren und bezahlbaren
energieversorgung
putin frei müsse man werden hat er zu
beginn gesagt und eine
laufzeitverlängerung der akw noch nicht
ganz abgeschrieben und die ja sagt er
manche entscheidung und damit meint er
beispielsweise nord stream 2 die würde
man heute wahrscheinlich anders dreßen
nina scheer ist die nächste rednerin
klima und energiepolitische sprecherin
der spd fraktion
russlands auf die opa eines aufs
schärfste zu verurteilen das möchte ich
noch mal hier ganz klar betonen und ich
danke auch präsident selensky für seine
heute an uns gerichteten worte es gibt
keine mauer es gibt solidarität und
hilfe es gibt das gemeinsame ziel des
friedens auch wenn der weg dahin noch
gefunden werden muss und nicht in allen
fragen der umsetzbarkeit für eben diesen
frieden übereinstimmung das leben ist
ich begrüße ausdrücklich dass die
bundesregierung trotz dieser
völkerrechtlich eindeutigen lage alles
versucht um auch auf dem diplomatischen
weg weiterhin darauf hinzuwirken dass
der krieg schnellstmöglich beendet
der krieg hat auch eine
energiepolitische dimension wenn unser
land zu 55 prozent abhängig vom
gasimporte aus russland ist und von
russland nun in europa kriegt es geht
verdeutlicht dies in drastischer weise
welche gefahr im pop abhängigkeiten
darstellen dies gilt erst recht wenn es
um energie rohstoffe und damit letztlich
um fragen der daseinsvorsorge geht
einem bagger kommt gleichwohl angesichts
der hiermit verbundenen folgewirkungen
nicht in betracht umso mehr muss die
abhängigkeit von fossilen ressourcen und
übrigens auch ohne einen krieg durch den
beschleunigten umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien bände
ist dieser reich das müssen die
bezugsquellen für importe aufgeteilt und
beziehungsweise diversifiziert werden an
beiden
unter hochdruck gearbeitet
wichtig ist dass dies nun die dass die
nun zu verkraften maßnahmen zugleich den
beschleunigten umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien dienen denn auch lng terminals
können nur dann diesen weg dienen wenn
sie zugleich wasserstoff anlandung
ermöglichen
alles andere wäre sowohl im kampf gegen
den klimawandel als auch zur loslösung
von endlichen fossilen ressourcen nicht
verantwortbar in diesem sinne wie auch
aus weiteren gründen sind die mit dem
vorliegenden antrag von cdu csu
offenkundig verfolgten
laufzeitverlängerung für atomkraftwerke
klar abzulehnen atomenergie ist schwer
regelbar
risikobehaftet die teuerste form der
energiegewinnung und erschwert mit ihrer
unflexibilität einen weiteren aufwuchs
erneuerbare energien die arbeiten sich
sparen sie haben es ja angesprochen was
sie hier programmatisch verfolgen sie
arbeiten sich an unserem
koalitionsvertrag so wird als wir daraus
nicht investieren
und die von ihnen etwa vorgeschlagene
absenkung der eeg umlage sie haben sogar
sortiert dass sie das mitte februar
erwähnt hätten das haben wir schon
längst im januar auf den weg gebracht
also der schuh wird anders und
die aussagen des antrags sie
beschleunigten energiewende sind zudem
höchst widersprüchlich wenn sie
offenkundig ein problem mit windenergie
an land haben ersparen sie haben
übrigens in ihrer rede kein einziges mal
war mal das wort erneuerbare energien in
den mund genommen das finde ich sehr
bezeichnend was ist ihre aussage zu
turbo wert den sie bei der 9 energien
anzünden wollen wenn sie dann noch
zuvor die akzeptanz frage zitat geklärt
haben wollen zudem mit dem zitat damit
die einbeziehung der belange der
anwohner ja das ist auch wieder zum
schlag war was heißt denn das bitte
schön hunderttausende anwohnerinnen und
anwohner leiden unter
atemwegserkrankungen unter stickoxiden
und anderen schadstoffen im zusammenhang
mit der verbrennung fossiler ressourcen
stehen sie machen hier wieder ein kampf
fällt auf windenergie ist keine
bedrohung sondern die tragende säule der
energiewende in erneuerbare energien
bringen freiheit weg folgt abhängigkeit
lassen sie endlich die ca
abstandsregelungen in bayern fallen wir
brauchen gegen das fiktive auf die
heimische wertschöpfung des wochenend
unabhängigkeit und möglichkeiten der
begrenzung des klimawandels wir brauchen
keine verhinderungs gesetze machen sie
bitte bei ihnen zu hause ihre
hausaufgaben wenn es souveränität in die
überschrift ihres antrages schafft in
bezug auf energie dann lösen sie doch
bitte endlich diese eklatanten
widersprüche auf es geht bei allem aber
auch im energie sicherheit
wären etwa nordex seine
rotorblattproduktion in rostock schließt
um sie ins ausland zu verlegen ist dies
längst keine reine
unternehmensentscheidungen mehr nein es
geht hier um den verlust von
zukunftsweisenden arbeitsplätze und um
energiesicherheit im zweifel hat in
solchen fragen meines erachtens der
staat auch eine garantenstellung
gleiches gilt etwa zur sicherung von
gasspeichern und auch deren füllstände
heute abend wird das im bundestag hier
noch debattiert unter einbeziehung
unseres bundeslandes übrigens falls hier
diese angriffe noch mal kommen sollten
mit einer reihe bereits auf den weg
gebrachten maßnahmen werden mit der
ampel koalition umfassend energiewende
hemmnisse beseitigt die seit dem letzten
stark marktgetriebenen verteuerung der
fossilen energien es ist übrigens eine
reine fossile energie krise er hat
bereits vor dem völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff auf größte land in russlands auf
die ukraine zu sozialen härten geführt
daher wurden richtigerweise schnell
entlastungen beschlossen so mit dem
inzwischen sogar verdoppelten
heizkostenzuschuss oft um mehr 270 euro
aber auch mit der zur jahresmitte
bevorstehende absenkung der eeg umlage
auf null die heute in den bundestag
eingebracht wird über weitere entlastung
wird verhandelt
hierbei es festzuhalten
die preissteigerungen basieren heute
nicht auf tatsächliche verknappung
sondern auch erwartungen es ist somit
auch unsere aufgabe spekulationen einen
wirksamen riegel vorzuschieben
die notwendigkeit entschleunigten
schädigt und stieg auf erneuerbare
energien sollte als erkenntnis die
chance begriffen werden völker
verständigen die weltweite abhängigkeit
einer wachsenden bevölkerung von immer
weniger wir haben den fossilen
ressourcen zu überwinden im sinne von
freiheit und frieden ihr antrag hängt in
allen sinnvollen punkten dem handeln der
regierungskoalition hinterher und wird
uns auch aus diesem grund im wege das
sofort abstimmung abgelehnt vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
nina schiffer das klima und
energiepolitische sprecherin der
spd-fraktion wir sind hier im deutschen
bundestag bei der befassung mit einem
antrag aus der unionsfraktion in dem es
um die energieversorgung geht sicher
soll sie sein bezahlbar soll sie sein
sagt die union ihr habt hat dafür die
lassen und dann den vorschlag gemacht
und zu diesen vorschlägen äußert sich
jetzt kasten hilse aus der fw-fraktion
wo er sprecher für klimaschutz und
energie ist frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren liebe landsleute wäre es
nicht so traurig dann könnte man darüber
lachen jetzt da die elementare
versorgung der bevölkerung auch und
insbesondere mit bezahlbarer energie
aufs höchste gefährdet es kommt sogar
die unionsfraktion mit einem antrag um
die ecke den sie in der vorankündigung
hochtrabend zeitenwende in der die
politik nannten die zeitenwende
energiepolitik sie nannten sie nur
energiewende führte letztendlich zu den
höchsten strompreisen der welt und hatte
während 16 jahre merkel allerhöchste
priorität in der politik der cdu aber
genau andersherum als sie sich heute
gerieren energie sollte musste unbedingt
teurer ihre verfügbarkeit drastisch
reduziert werden das war erklärtes ziel
ihrer fraktion natürlich tatkräftig
angefeuert durch die restlichen
altparteien die opportunisten und vor
allem die grünen kommunisten die wir in
der zwischenzeit in allen fraktionen
außer der afg finden und dafür wurden
diverse maßnahmen betroffen von der
abschaltung der kern und kohlekraftwerke
der aufgabe von braunkohletagebauen bis
hin zur effektiven verhinderung der
gewinnung von erdgas aus ertragreichen
deutschen feldern stets flankiert von
energiegewinnung verhinderungs maßnahmen
mittels diverser steuern auf die noch
verfügbaren energieträger will bis hin
zu deren verbot ihr ziel war es
eindeutig zug und zug die energie gas
kohle benzin und strom stark zu
verteuern um den verbrauch drastisch
abzusenken alles natürlich wie immer
begründet mit der hypothese dass die
menschen gemachten co2 emissionen das
klima maßgeblich beeinflussen profis
nach wie vor keinen einzigen
wissenschaftlichen beweis gibt tausend
wissenschaftler weltweit widersprechen
dieser zur religion erhobenen
behauptungen fakt ist sie wollten von
anfang an die zeitenwende sie nannten
sie nur anders nämlich zunächst große
transformation und dann im herzlichen
einvernehmen mit dem world economic
forum und klaus schwab the great reset
durch den krieg in der ukraine wird nun
offenkundig dass ihre tagträumereien wie
seifenblasen zerplatzen in der physik
und in der politik geht es eben nicht
darum was man sich wünscht sondern um
realitäten die realität ist dass ein
industrieland wie deutschland nicht mit
wind und sonne sicher mit strom versorgt
werden kann
deswegen
folgendes zitat mit genehmigung der
präsidentin der bundestag fordert die
bundesregierung auf offen und ohne
vorfestlegungen und im hinblick auf alle
gegebenen rechtlichen technischen und
betriebswirtschaftlichen möglichkeiten
umfassend zu prüfen ob und wie der
weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken
zunächst im streckt betrieb zur co2
armen und sicheren stromversorgung in
den kommenden jahren beitragen kann eine
solche prüfung darf anders als der
prüfer merkt des bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und klima sowie des
bundesministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz keine politische
auftragsarbeit seien bei der das
ergebnis der von dem einen grünen
minister angekündigten prüfung schon vor
deren beginn von der anderen grünen
ministerin verkündet wird jetzt müsste
eigentlich beifall von den rängen der
union kommen denn das wort für wort aus
ihrem antrag dieser forderung schließen
wir uns natürlich an wobei wir die
sofortige verlängerung der laufzeiten
der letzten drei kernkraftwerke ergänzt
durch die wieder inbetriebnahme der am
jahresanfang stillgelegten kkw es als
dringend erforderlich ansehen
zusätzlich lassen sich unsere
derzeitigen probleme wesentlich und vor
allem sehr schnell entschärfen wenn sie
der klima religion abschwört innen und
zb unseren antrag vom zehnten elften
2021 mit der drucksache nummer 20 34
zustimmten in diesem antrag fordern wir
unter anderem den betrieb von
kohlekraftwerken die dem stand der
technik entsprechen uneingeschränkt zu
ermöglichen und sämtliche bemühungen zum
ausstieg aus dieser technik zu
unterlassen bzw zu beenden und zur
sicherung der elektrizitätsversorgung
auf die landesregierungen einzuwirken
notfalls sofort per erlass durch die
bundesregierung eine provisorische
laufzeitverlängerung für die noch in
betrieb befindlichen noch
betriebsbereiten kohlekraftwerke und
wenn sie wirklich die absicht hätten die
notlage zu beenden zumindest auf
mittlere sicht den preisanstieg zu
dämpfen dann könnten sie mit uns die
voraussetzung für die förderung
heimischen erdgases zum beispiel
schiefergestein kohleflözen schaffen
deren lagerstätten lagerstätte in umfang
und die gewinnung sind bekannt was fehlt
es allein der politische wille lieber
wollen sie sie alle auch sie herr
gremmels das glas das genau auf die
gleiche art und weise gewonnen wird
übers meer schippern aber was tut man
nicht alles als knallharter lobbyist der
amerikanischen rohstoffindustrie
sowie viele energiepolitiker der
altparteien vorrangig die interessen der
wind und solar branche und der
amerikanischen rohstoffindustrie
vertreten so dienen sich viele
gesundheitspolitiker der altparteien bei
der pharmaindustrie an sie wollen gegen
viele bedenken hinsichtlich der
fehlenden wirkung der zu injizieren
stoffe deren teilweise katastrophale
nebenwirkung und der aussage von vielen
wissenschaftlern und juristin dass eine
impfpflicht unter den gegebenen
umständen
verfassungswidrig sei eine allgemeine
impfpflicht beschließen selbst und als
ich das las schnürte es mir das herz
zusammen schwangere ab dem vierten monat
sollen sich unter umständen gegen ihren
eigenen willen und natürlich ohne den
noch nicht artikulieren willen des noch
nicht geborenen erdenbürgers einen stoff
infizieren lassen dessen nebenwirkungen
noch nicht umfassend bekannt sind und
das obwohl mehrere studien zum beispiel
das großbritannien zeigen dass viel
geboten und rot geworden weil gebärenden
den diese stoffe initiiert wurden um ein
vielfaches höher liegen als es der
normalfall wäre diese menschenverachtung
macht mich fassungslos
ich hoffe dass die armen kinderseelen
sie bis an ihr lebensende und darüber
hinaus verfolgen
ob der antrieb dieser sogenannten
energie und gesundheitspolitiker es gibt
auch weniger ausnahmen muss man hier
sagen nur der schnöde mammon ist oder ob
da mehr dahinter steckt werden wir bald
erfahren
zum wohle des deutschen volkes ist das
handeln dieser korrupten sollte die
demokraten jedenfalls nicht ich spreche
hier und jetzt die wenigen ausnahmen an
überzeugen sie ihre kollegen den pfad
der zerstörung deutschland zu verlassen
ihre energiewende ist gescheitert sie
war es bereits seit jahren der ukraine
krieg macht dies nur für jedermann
sichtbar leider enthält der hier
vorgelegten antrag jede menge klima
gewöhnt deswegen hier in leider ablehnen
müssen das heißt aber nicht dass wir
nicht in zukunft gemeinsam und zum wohle
unseres volkes konstruktiv an lösungen
arbeiten können ich bedanke mich
vielmals für ihre aufmerksamkeit
der bundestag diskutiert naja jedenfalls
überwiegend über einen antrag der
unionsfraktion zum thema bezahlbare
energieversorgung die union fordert
darin unter anderem von der
bundesregierung weitere forderungen
diesem schnell umzusetzen sind um
beamten dem preisanstieg etwa
entgegenzuwirken und hat dafür
vorschläge gemacht wir verbinden ist die
nächste rednerin stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90
jahre regierung
5861 tage
5861 tage hatten sie zeit um deutschland
auf den weg der energiesicherheit auf
den weg der energie souveränität zu
bringen mit erneuerbaren energien und
energieeffizienz und man muss es so klar
sagen sie haben ist gründlich versemmelt
sie fordern jetzt entschlossenheit ja in
der tat die hätten wir in den letzten
jahren dringend gebraucht als sie die
mehrheiten hatten doch das gegenteil von
entschlossenheit nämlich die ideologie
und die freundlichkeit von union haben
uns erst in diese aktuelle misere
gebracht sehr teurer sehr teure fossile
energie und eine geopolitisch hoch
problematische abhängigkeit ist ihr
verdienst liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der cdu und csu der schreckliche
angriffskrieg und seine konsequenzen für
die menschen in der ukraine und für die
europäische energieversorgung führt uns
die fehler der vergangenheit deutlich
vor augen wenn es schon in den letzten
jahren konsequent versäumt wurde müssen
wir nun jetzt umso schneller unabhängig
werden von den fossilen energieträgern
und
dazu sagen sie herr spahn in ihrer rede
nichts auch auf den ersten seiten ihres
antrags nichts dazu erst nachdem sie
noch einmal den umweg durch die
sackgasse atomkraft genommen haben kommt
auf punkt
16.16 kommt in ihrem antrag dann endlich
der entscheidende game changer nämlich
demnach soll die bundesregierung jetzt
endlich mal beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
den turbo anzünden halleluja dass ich
das bei der union noch erleben darf
glauben sie mir dafür brauchen wir keine
aufforderung der union
wir freuen uns natürlich wenn sie
ankündigen das was wir jetzt an
wichtigen gesetzen auf den weg bringen
zu unterstützen vielleicht helfen sie
uns auch noch weitere dinge auf den weg
zu bringen ich freue mich drauf ich
möchte sie aber daran erinnern dass
unter unions geführter regierung die
solarindustrie aus dem land getrieben
wurde das bei der windenergie die
historisch niedrigsten ausbauzahlen seit
der einführung des eeg es erzielt worden
sind und durch sie zu verantworten sind
ihre politik hat den erneuerbaren
standort in deutschland entfernt
und diese neue bundesregierung dies
jetzt seit 100 tagen im amt seit 100
tagen seit morgen morgen seit 100 tagen
und sie startet mit einer sie startet in
einer massiven energiepreis krise in der
wir stecken mit biss bisher nicht
dagewesenen preise für gas und kohle und
wir sind daran die schuld aber wir
reagieren schnell und entschlossen auf
diese akute krise die aus der
abhängigkeit von fossilen energien
entstanden ist und zwar handeln wir mit
kurzfristigen hilfen und mit einer
klaren politischen linie ich bin froh
dass der wirtschaftsminister angekündigt
hat und den kartellbehörden
die kartellbehörden aufgefordert hat
klar zu klären ob die absprachen von den
konzernen dafür verantwortlich sind dass
die preise an die tankstellen so hoch
sind und schon in dieser woche bringt
der gesetzentwürfe auf den weg um die
bürger bei den energiekosten zu
entlasten
wir schaffen die eeg umlage ab darüber
reden wir heute noch gewähren einen
heizkostenzuschuss auch den beschließen
wir heute für bedürftige haushalt und
wir schaffen auch ein sofort zuschlag
für kinder dass sie nachdem die die
menschen jetzt dringend braucht und die
werden heute auf den weg gebracht
gleichzeitig beschleunigen wir jetzt
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien robert
habeck hat in einem rekordtempo ein
gesetzentwurf zur entfesselung der
erneuerbaren energien vorgelegt das ist
der weitestgehende entwurf den wir
jemals gesehen haben und damit
beschleunigen wir jetzt insbesondere den
ausbau von wind- und solarenergie mit
der perspektive eines klimaneutralen
strom systems bis zum jahr 2035
natürlich können wir nicht alle
versäumnisse aus vielen jahren
rückwärtsgewandte politik mit einem
schlag auflösen deshalb wird nach dem
muster paket das sommer paket folgen die
reform des strommarkts stets an
kohleausstieg bis 2030 der aufbau einer
wasserstoffwirtschaft aber ich sage
diese regierung hat in den ersten 100
tagen mehr angeschoben als so manche
vorgängerregierung in einer ganzen
legislaturperiode
wer sparen ersparen wir wir wollen alles
alles wollen wir dafür tun damit die
russischen energieimporte so schnell wie
möglich überflüssig werden wir tun
deswegen alles für einen schnelleren
ausbau der erneuerbaren und trotzdem
geht das nicht mit einem fingerschnippen
und der joker der joker der energie
souveränität ist die energieeffizienz
wir müssen und wir können massiv den
energieverbrauch reduzieren
auch dazu in ihrer rede kein wort herr
sparen die energieeffizienz offensive
hilft uns auch bei der reduzierung der
laufenden kosten denn entscheidend ist
doch dass wir dauerhaft dass wir
dauerhaft von hohen energiekosten
wegkommen das geht nicht über ständig
neue subventionen für den verbrauch von
fossiler energie das wäre ein fass ohne
boden und spielt zusätzlich noch mehr
geld in putins kriegskasse der weg zu
dauerhaft verlässlichen energiepreisen
geht nur über konsequente
zukunftsinvestitionen in
energieeffiziente technik in sparsame
fahrzeuge und verbrauchsarme gebäude es
nützt den mieterinnen doch am wenigsten
wenn sie einfach immer nur geld in die
fossilen konzerne überweisen sie
brauchen wohnungen die so gut gedämmt
sein dass sie auf dauer nur noch die
hälfte der energie zum heizen benötigen
dafür brauchen wir jetzt herr sparen wir
brauchen jetzt rekordinvestitionen für
besseres wohnen und faire wärme mit
unserer erneuerbaren und energie spar
offensive arbeiten wir als ampel am
klimaschutz und sichern eine souveräne
energieversorgung wie ernst es ihnen
damit es ihnen wohl der union - können
sie in den kommenden wochen und monaten
beweisen hier im bundestag und dem
bundesrat nach 16 jahren
investitionsbremse der union können sie
jetzt helfen die investitions turbo
einzuschalten
ich hoffe sie sind dabei ich bin sehr
dankbar dass wir in der ampelkoalition
hier für den gemeinsamen willen haben
und ich sage ihnen ihr im parlament sind
wir dafür alles geben vielen dank
julia von den stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen sieht in den vergangenen 16
jahren einen
sichtlich und ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien in dieser zeit und geld
forderungen aus der union für eine turbo
ausbau jetzt für
die parlaments vizepräsidentin petra pau
bietet noch mal nach fast schon
flehentlich die abgeordneten um
einhaltung der redezeit der hintergrund
ist dass petra pau und katrin göring
eckardt sich heute die parlamentssitzung
und auch morgen teilen müssen dann alle
andern krank sind und das nicht
übernehmen können jetzt ist wiesen und
lötzsch am pool stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion die partei
hat ja unter den präsidenten
nach 16 lange regierungsjahren legen cdu
und csu einen umfangreichen
forderungskatalog vor ohne ein wort
wirklicher selbstkritik und ohne darüber
zu sprechen dass sie den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien effektiv und aktiv
behindert haben und das ist nicht in
ordnung damen und herren und ohne
darüber zu sprechen dass unter ihrer
verantwortung die öffentliche
infrastruktur zerfallen ist allein auf
der ebene der kommunen müssten schon
längst 150 milliarden euro investiert
worden seien und sie sagen in ihrem
antrag auch überhaupt nichts zur
finanzierung und ich kann ihnen auch
erklären warum sie das nicht tun denn
sie wollen weiter an der schwarzen null
und an der schuldenbremse festhalten
sie wollen steuererhöhungen für
vermögende verhindert und ich kann ihnen
sagen wir wollen das nicht wir wollen
endlich gerechte steuer damen und herren
und sie unterstützen das 100 milliarden
auf rüstungs paket der bundesregierung
und auch das ist falsch
bundes
energieminister robert habeck sagt den
menschen wechselt doch einfach den
stromanbieter wenn es euch zu teuer ist
das zeigt kollege habe ich von
erschreckender unkenntnis die ärmsten in
unserer gesellschaft zahlen die höchsten
strompreise denn sie können gar kein
strom tarif wählen sie müssen den tarif
nehmen den ihnen der grundversorger
anbietet und auf ihrer internetseite
schreiben sie von rahmenbedingen und
markttransparenz das ist kann ich ihnen
sagen wirklich marktliberaler uns in
meine damen und herren die eu kommission
ist im vergleich zu ihnen geradezu
revolutionär im strategiepapier der eu
steht regierungen dürfen in solchen
ausnahmesituationen
energiepreise für die verbraucher
festsetzen und ich frage mich warum
macht das die bundesregierung nicht und
es ist auch möglich so die eu kommission
weiter gewinne bei den energieversorgern
abzuschätzen die gerade prächtig
verdienen er habe ich an der stelle
müssten sie doch mal endlich beherzt
eingreifen das ist das gebot der stunde
oder orientieren als mal in anderen
ländern schauen wir nach griechenland
der premierminister ein christdemokrat
kollege sparen will massiv in die
großhandelsmärkte für energie eingreifen
er will den gaspreis auf vorkrisenniveau
deckeln eine höchstgrenze für tägliche
preisschwankungen einführen und die
gewinnmarge der stromversorger begrenzen
und spekulativen handel verbieten daran
könnte man sich orientieren meint tag
jetzt komme ich zur sg herr lindner hat
der ja den eindruck erweckt er wäre der
eigentliche chef hier in der
bundesregierung will einen tank rabatt
warum fordern sie eigentlich keinen
mieten rabatt und keinen rabatt für
öffentliche verkehrsmittel das wäre der
richtige weg meine damen und herren
und es ist auch völlig klar wer heute
gerade von der energie krise profitiert
es sind die
ölraffinerien und den müssen die
krisengewinner wirklich weg gesteuert
werden das wäre eine politische aufgabe
meine damen und herren wir
haben heute
zu anfang der sitzung eine sehr
beeindruckende rede gehört und ich kann
für meine fraktion noch einmal ganz
deutlich sagen wir wollen alles tun mit
allen menschen gemeinsam die für den
frieden einstehen dass der krieg gegen
die ukraine endlich beendet wird alle
menschen haben ein recht darauf in
frieden zu leben und auch wir sind
verantwortlich dafür dieses recht mit zu
garantieren und darum kann ich nur sagen
endlich die waffen nieder
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege michael kruse
für die fdp
und michael kruse ist energiepolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst eine
gewisse sprachlosigkeit hiernach der
nach der video botschaft macht mich
sprachlos und ich bedauere dass wir es
im parlament angesichts dieser
historischen rede nicht geschafft haben
das unsere unterstützung in worte zu
fassen präsident sie lenski hat sehr
treffend formuliert dass
die wirtschaftspolitik des westens als
ein sehr wesentliches instrument ansieht
und wir reden ja heute im bereich der
energiepolitik vor allem darüber welche
macht wir haben um entscheidungen anders
zu treffen ich zitiere im präsident
seeländer sagte wirtschaft wirtschaft
wirtschaft dürfe nicht alles sein es
dürfe nicht das entscheidende kriterium
seines dürfe nicht das einzige kriterium
sein und in der tat unsere
wirtschaftspolitik muss in diesen zeiten
freiheits politik sein unsere
wirtschafts und energiepolitik sie muss
friedenspolitik werden und deswegen bin
ich dem bundesfinanzminister auch sehr
dankbar dass er an dieser stelle
rahmen der aussprache zur
regierungserklärung klar formuliert hat
das erneuerbare energien freiheit nr
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
und die hat sie die bundesregierung die
regierung hat in den letzten wochen sehr
viel getan zum thema
versorgungssicherheit zum thema
schaffung von energiesicherheit und
es nötigt mir persönlich großen respekt
ab dass ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
der erste grüne wirtschaftsminister
an das tabu herangeht seiner partei und
sagt nicht mal das länger laufen lassen
der kernkraftwerke ist mehr ein
diesen respekt könnten sie der minister
ja auch entgegenbringen und
die tatsache dass dann eine prüfung
erfolgt an deren ende steht
frau kollegin klöckner das war etwas
später nachdem die analyse erfolgt ist
da hat er das ausgeschlossen das stimmt
die tatsache dass am ende dieser
analysen allerdings steht dass auch hier
die letzte regierung die große koalition
mit einem wirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier dafür gesorgt hat dass
wesentlich die sicherheitsüberprüfung
ausgesetzt werden im jahr 2019 die
zehnjährige sicherheitsüberprüfung die
angestanden hätte nicht mehr hat
stattfinden müssen führt dazu dass diese
kraftwerke mittlerweile ein großes und
jeden tag größeres sicherheitsrisiko
darstellen und deswegen muss man am ende
dieser analyse doch feststellen das ist
sehr klug dass den weg zu gehen den die
regierung ihr ziel geht um hier energie
riese wahrheit herbeizuführen nämlich
all diejenigen kraftwerke mit ressourcen
zu versorgen die die stabilität im netz
garantieren können auch wenn wir zum
beispiel mal eine dunkel flaute haben
und deswegen lade ich sie herzlich ein
die analyse mal zu lesen und dann auch
zum richtigen schluss zu kommen denn sie
zeigt wir hier alle im raum wir wären
verantwortlich dafür dass diese
kernkraftwerke jeden tag unsicherer
werden wir während dafür verantwortlich
im event fall zu erklären warum das denn
unbedingt hat stattfinden müssen und
wenn sie verantwortung bereit sind dafür
zu übernehmen schön und gut die mehrheit
in diesem hause ist es nicht und ich
persönlich nicht sehr lang und
herr kollege sparen sie haben ihren
antrag vorgestellt und ich fand das sehr
gute weiterentwicklung zu unserer
letzten debatte die etwas hitziger war
vielleicht auch ernsthaftigkeit des
themas nicht an jeder stelle angemessen
ich fand es im stil besser ich fand das
auch vom inhalt besser was wir hier
heute vorgelegt haben und das insgesamt
finde ich für die ernsthaftigkeit dieser
debatte begrüßen sie werden unsere
bestandsaufnahme morgen sind die 100
tage für die ampel regierung um unsere
bestandsaufnahme zu ihrer broker zeit
ihrer groko arbeit kann ich ihnen
allerdings nicht ersparen denn sie ist
eine wesentliche basis warum wir heute
darüber diskutieren
in einem nachtwächter staat darf der
nachtwächter nicht schlafen herr kollege
sparen in einem nachtwächter staat in
dem der wettbewerb funktionieren soll
muss der wettbewerb vom nachtwächter
geschützt werden der nachtwächter der
den wettbewerb im gasmarkt hätte sichern
soll dies in den letzten jahren peter
altmaier er war von ihrer
und die tatsache dass wir heute abend
überhaupt noch über gasspeicher
regulierung sprechen müssen ist dem
umstand geschuldet dass sie den
wettbewerb nicht geschützt haben und die
tatsache dass russland und seine
unternehmen einen krieg im
wirtschaftlichen bereich mit dem
instrument der entleerung der
gasspeicher mit dem verkürzen der
gaslieferungen im spot gegen uns führen
hätte ihren wirtschaftsminister seit
letztem april auffallen können und die
tatsache dass sie abgewählt worden liegt
vielleicht auch daran dass sie mehr mit
wahlkampf und ihren internen querelen
beschäftigt waren als mit der tatsache
dass hier etwas vorbereitet wird was
einen veritablen schaden in deutschland
hätte herbeiführen kann und es ist
einzig dem milden winter zu verdanken
dass der schaden nicht eingetreten ist
und deswegen sollten sie als allererstes
dafür die verantwortung übernehmen das
vermisse ich allerdings in ihrem antrag
und ich finde es gut wenn sie zumindest
die realität zur kenntnis nehmen würden
und dann auch ihre pflicht als
opposition sie wollen ja eigentlich eine
alternative sein und dann sollten sie
vielleicht nicht nur aufschreiben was es
schon gibt
heizkostenzuschuss erhöhen haben wir
doch erledigt ist doch schon durch
entfernungspauschale sind wir doch dran
anhebung grundfreibetrag lauter dinge
die sie fordern die wir schon machen ich
lade sie herzlich ein mal dinge
vorzulegen die wir nicht schon machen
dann bin ich gerne bereit darüber mit
ihnen zu sprechen herzlichen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit
michael kruse war das energiepolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion und mit einer
energiepolitischen sprecherin geht mit
seiner wirtschaftspolitischen sprecherin
geht es weiter wenn sie denn aufgerufen
wird da sehen wir sie schon julia
klöckner für die unions fraktions und
jetzt darf sie auch tatsächlich ans pult
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
herr hilfe von der afd
sie haben uns alle hier vorhin
vielleicht mit selektiver ausnahmen als
korrupte
demokraten genannt pseudo demokraten
haben sie uns genannt und hier wird
gerade noch beifall geklatscht ich finde
sie machen nichts der demokratie sondern
kann putin mit solchen aussagen alle er
und ein zweiter satz
sie haben gesagt wir reden uns von wind
und energie abhängig machen in
deutschland das seien noch
unberechenbarer als herr putin ich finde
das
menschenverachtend wir haben von nicht
einmal drei stunden haben wir den
präsidenten aus der ukraine hier gehört
und sie setzen wind und sonne mit einer
unberechenbarkeit von handy gleich ich
finde das peinlich ich finde dass
blamabel und so was gehört nicht hier
ins parlament muss ich wirklich sehr
sicher
verlinken sie haben für die gründen
gesprochen bin ja stark erstaunt dass
für sie die neue erneuerbaren energien
eine große rolle spielen darüber bin ich
nicht verstaubt das ihnen aber die
bürgerinnen und bürger die unternehmen
überhaupt kein wort wert sind was sie
heute aktuell zu tragen und am preis
explosionen zu stellen haben jeden tag
im alltag unser antrag den wir heute
stellen der reagiert ganz klar darauf
was zum beispiel was zum beispiel eine
bäckerei in nordrhein-westfalen zeit
jetzt einmal halt jetzt im monat 700
euro mehr an kosten doch einmal sagen
ist viele panne für ab worte wie uns
vielleicht schauen wir auf die
großindustrie ludwigshafen bei uns in
rheinland pfalz die basf hat am standort
dort über 30.000 mitarbeitern allein in
den monaten januar und februar sind die
energiekosten um 600 millionen euro ein
weltweiter konzern der größte
chemiekonzern gestiegen das hat
auswirkungen auf unsere volkswirtschaft
das hat auswirkungen auf unseren
standort das hat auswirkungen auf die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer das
hat auswirkungen auf unser land und
darauf geben wir eine antwort wenn der
staat kann abgaben und steuern senken er
kann sofort reagieren und deshalb haben
wir als union diesen antrag eben auch
eingebracht und dann möchte ich noch ein
weiteres sagen damit sich hier auch
keine menschen festsetzen übrigens die
grünen sind ja in zehn bundesländern mit
an der regierung in baden-württemberg
stellen sie sogar den
ministerpräsidenten wer hinten in der
windkraft ausbaufähigkeit hinterher das
ist warten würden werden und dann
schauen wir uns mal den energiemix an
wir haben den energiemix gesteigert mit
erneuerbaren energien
2005 lag er bei 11
und 2020 lager bei etwa 43 und wenn sie
sagen wir haben als koalition als unions
geführten regierungen nichts gemacht
dann können sie entweder mit rechnen
oder sie haben vorstellungen die weder
bezahlbar noch umsetzbar sind und
deshalb bitte ich sehe bitte ich sie
teil geht wieder ein blick auf die
normalen menschen hier in diesem land zu
haben kollege selber habe ich auch sehr
klar mit blick auf unsere
unternehmerinnen unternehmer gerade hier
in deutschland den häufig vorgeworfen
wird zuerst das geschäft und dann die
moral kolleginnen müssen wir und wollen
wir heute danke sagen dass die
wirtschaft unsere deutschen
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer so
geschlossen hinter den sanktionen gegen
russland stehen das ist vorbildlich das
verdient dank und ich sage danke im
namen der cdu und csu bundestagsfraktion
für diese klare haltung irgendwie hatte
sie eine fragen oder bemerkungen aus der
grünen gerne
vielen dank frau kollegin
frage zu lassen ich möchte mich auch
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den
unternehmen in diesem land die gerade
lasten schultern ich glaube aber dass
wir in der diskussion die sehr ernsthaft
wahrnehme und ein gutes gesamtbild
machen müssen auch von den
energiemärkten die wir aktuell haben und
das sind erwartungs märkte das sind
psychologische märkte mit konkreten
auswirkungen
ich habe mir heute den ölpreis verlauf
angeschaut der letzten woche vor einer
woche waren wir bei 138 wtl brennt es
ein bisschen drunter jetzt sind wir bei
199 in einer woche also ein abfall von
fast 40% das alles müssen wir
einkalkulieren auch in die maßnahmen die
zu treffen sind was ich sagen will wir
brauchen ein gesamtkonzept und das legt
diese bundesregierung vor in dem sie
sagt wir gucken uns die effizienz
maßnahmen an wir gucken uns die frage an
wie wir härtefälle glasindustrie bayern
zum beispiel ist ein härtefall annehmen
und einzelmaßnahmen treffen aber die
frage hat an sie ist ob es denn eine
konsistente strategie ist zu sagen wir
senken die mehrwertsteuer umfang von 20
milliarden euro wir sagen gleichzeitig
wird gesagt dass öffentlich wir wollen
ein embargo und damit letztlich uns den
gar hass gashahn selber zu drehen und
zum dritten zu sagen wir möchten einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt vorlegen also
wir müssen sie sich auch mal selber
entscheiden was sie wollen ich verstehe
ihr konzept bislang überhaupt nicht
danke schön herr kollege dass sie das
konzept von uns nicht verstehen muss
nicht am absender nämlich an uns liegen
kann auch am empfänger leben zwei hunde
zweiter punkt was konsistenzen angelangt
der staat
verdient bei der inflation bei jedem
prozentpunkt zehn milliarden euro mit
und ich finde die bürgerinnen und bürger
haben nicht große reden verdient
reden die besagen dass sei eine
psychologische wirkung ich kann ihnen
sagen eine krankenschwester die bahn
ihren wahlkreis jeden morgen von
simmertal nach bad kreuznach ins
krankenhaus fährt 32 kilometer sie kann
nicht hinzunehmen wenn sie den nimmt
kann sie schon machen braucht sie zwei
stunden um anzukommen die spürt mit
psychologisch den höheren energiepreis
dies wird bei jeder tankfüllung in ihrem
schmalen geldbeutel dass hier etwas
nicht stimmt und hier kann die
bundesregierung reagieren denn wir
wissen dass etwa die hälfte steuern und
abgaben sind und die idee jetzt der
regierung ist übrigens der fdp die
vorher vom großen entfesselung von
bürokratie monster gesprochen hat ist
jetzt ein tankgutschein
die beamten das kann nicht allen ernstes
eure antwort auf diese probleme sein die
wir hier in diesem land gerade raum und
deshalb haben wir diesen antrag gestellt
wird konkret es gibt maßnahmen da bin
ich ganz bei ihnen die langfristig
wirken müssen mittelfristig und deshalb
auch nochmal stichwort ausbau
erneuerbarer energien nach haben sie uns
an ihrer seite und wir haben gezeigt
dass wir es vorangebracht haben als
union aber wir müssen jetzt kurzfristig
auch antworten haben und reagieren und
wir können kurzfristig reagieren und an
eines möchte sie noch erinnern als
minister habe seine regierungserklärung
gehalten hat haben wir darauf
geantwortet und haben die abschaffung
der e die umlage sofort gefordert und
nicht erst 2023 und jeder alle reaktion
ist gelächter gewesen und jetzt machen
wir es und deshalb sage ich bringt eine
erbschaft ja gerade mal gar nix um es
kurz zu sagen um das magma zusagen nicht
mal vor drei wochen haben sie über
diesen vorschlag der union gelacht die
eeg-umlage sofort abzuschaffen kurz
danach haben sie darüber gelacht als es
hieß wir müssen an der zapfsäule
entlasten dann gibt's den tankstellen
gutscheine könnten wir darüber lachen
und jetzt kommen wir zu einem nächsten
schritt steuern und abgaben runter sie
lachen heute noch ich werde ich kann
ihnen sagen sie werden dir etwas ändern
weil sie ständig der entwicklung
hinterher laufen und deshalb machen wir
diesen antrag um in die chance zu geben
zumindest teile davon umzusetzen
deshalb ich möchte zum schluss kommen
damit mein kollege der nachher noch zu
dem thema verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher reden wird ich will aber
nochmals an dieser stelle verdeutlichen
wie schwer gebeutelt und heftig zu
tragen einige der unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer in deutschland haben und
darüber müssen wir hier auch reden bei
dieser debatte und es geht um diejenigen
deren rohstoffpreise gestiegen sind
deren energiepreise gestiegen sind die
das nicht komplett umlegen können auf
die endverbraucher oder abnehmer preise
wir haben logistikunternehmen die sich
strecken müssen die papierindustrie die
stahlindustrie die glasindustrie die
alle sind gerade mit dem rücken an der
wand und da stimmt überall gesichter und
menschen hinten dran und deshalb sage
ich tun sie jetzt was das schließt nicht
aus dass wir auch langfristige konzepte
stichwort ausbau erneuerbarer energien
mitverfolgen aber jetzt sind sie gefragt
und nicht für große reden in der zukunft
julia klöckner war das für die
unionsfraktion
abgesehen davon wer wann geforderter
steht die eeg umlage ab zu senken oder
abzuschaffen
heute abend
gegen wahrscheinlich 20 21 uhr wird
zumindest hier in erster lesung über die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage debattiert im
bundestag
was ist der unterschied zwischen
berechenbar und unberechenbar sie können
wenn es berechenbar können sie berechnen
wie sich etwas oder jemand verhält wenn
es unberechenbar ist dann können sie es
eben nicht berechnen und dass ihre
politik ihre wirtschaftspolitik dazu
führen kann und höchstwahrscheinlich
wird dass es mehrere zehntausend tote
geben wird das hat ihnen der ausschuss
für folgenabschätzung in die bundestags
drucksache 17 5 672 geschrieben also
ihre politik ist auch unberechenbar die
viele milliarden euro kosten kann und
höchstwahrscheinlich wird und bzw auch
viele menschenleben und jetzt komme ich
nochmal auf die sogenannten korrupten
zoo demokraten dazu ich habe extra
gesagt das ist nicht sie alle betrifft
und mit korruption kennt sich die
cdu-fraktion aus masken deals millionen
die meisten oder sehr viele von den
abgeordneten da drüben in der linken
seite auf der linken seite sind direkt
haben direkt investiert in die wind-
oder in die solar branche das heißt sie
profitieren davon wenn sie hier quasi
die erneuerbaren energien vorantreiben
und da genau so ist es auch in so hab
ich es auch gemeinsam also ich möchte
noch einmal sagen dass es da ausnahmen
gibt und bei denen die habe ich auf
jeden fall nicht gemeint aber wie gesagt
die cdu fraktion kennt sich mit
korruption aus
kasten hielt er hornist
also erstens kann man das sicherlich im
protokoll nachlesen was sie gesagt haben
und zweitens besser ist der vorwurf
durch ihre wortmeldung hier eben nicht
geworden wenn sie behaupten ist sind nur
einige die keine korrupten pseudo
demokraten sind dann finde ich das kein
licht nicht immerhin
erst mal unter uns sie können ja ihren
hass nicht mehr sie gehören die jetzt
ihre parteitage so abhalten aber es gibt
schon einen gewissen stil in diesem
deutschen parlament und die bürgerinnen
und bürger die dafür arbeiten dass wir
bezahlt werden haben sowas nicht
verdient so wie sie sich hier vor und
auf schirm und deshalb sage ich noch mal
ich weise für alle zurück in dieser
gesamtheit dass dieser deutsche
bundestag weder teilweise noch
vollkommen oder in prozentsätzen aus
korrupten pseudo demokraten besteht sie
machen hat putin alle ehre mit solchen
aussagen
wir fahren in der debatte fort das wort
hat der kollege timon gremmels für die
spd-fraktion timon gremmels ist mitglied
im ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren es ist schon
atemberaubend in welcher geschwindigkeit
sich die union von ihrer regierung
center frau merkel distanziert und
ausgerechnet zwei ehemalige minister im
kabinett merkel
treten das erbe der kanzlerin mit
schüssen das ist in der tat sehr
beeindruckt meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren und ersparen wenn sie hier
sieben minuten reden und einen antrag
einbringen der über souveräne
energie-versorgung betitelt ist und ihn
dann nur ein feld atom und kohlekraft zu
verlängern wo kommt denn die rohstoffe
hier wo kommen denn die steinkohle wo
kommen denn die kohle wo kommt denn auch
das
uran hier das uran kommen bis schärfen
wir doch nicht in deutschland selbst das
ist das einzige was hinein zu fahren ist
sie haben nicht einen satz zu den
erneuerbaren energien hier betitelt herr
spahn ich glaube das sagt sehr viel über
ihre zukunftsfähigkeit meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren im einen wie
im antrag schreiben sie dann auch man
müsse den erneuerbaren energien
sozusagen ein turbo verpassen ja wer hat
denn blockiert in den letzten vier
jahren es war unter anderem herr nüßlein
als stellvertretender fraktions von der
herr frey fort als
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher beide
sind ja nicht mehr haben sind ja nicht
mehr angetreten wir wissen alle die
hintergründe aber sie haben doch
gebremst was den ausbau der erneuerbaren
an geht und wer hält sie denn auf
regieren sie doch in nordrhein westfalen
und bayern warum machen sie denn nicht
den turbo warum machen sie nicht mehr
ausbau erneuerbarer energien in
nordrhein westfalen warum schaffen sie
nicht die 10h regelungen bayern ab sie
haben doch die möglichkeit meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren handeln sie
so lange sie das noch können sie lange
ich dazu noch mehrheiten haben die ampel
liefert wir haben hier ein oster paket
auf den weg gebracht bzw noch hat es der
minister auf den weg gebracht das
parlament beschäftigt sich erst noch
aber ich kann ihnen sagen das hat es in
sich es ist die größte reform seit 21
jahren seit dem bestehen des eeg und das
zeigt wir wollen hier gestalten und wir
wollen uns unabhängig machen und zwar
mit erneuerbaren energien und wir laden
sie herzlich ein sozusagen nicht auf den
oppositions plätze zu verharren und
wohlfeile anträge zu schreiben sondern
mitzumachen und sich daran zu beteiligen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und da kommen wir jetzt zum thema der
energiekosten und der sogenannten
benzinpreis bremse von tobias hans also
muss man ja schon sehen da sitzt ein
kandidat so steht wo er mit dem rücken
an der wand ehrlich gesagt ich fand
dieses video auf mehreren ebenen so was
von deplatziert und unpassend dass das
nicht dafür schämt meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren das ist fremdschämen
und ich sage ihnen ganz einfach gucken
sie doch mal nach wie sich der
rohölpreis entwickelt hat die letzten
zwei wochen und wie sich der benzinpreis
entwickelt hat und dann sieht man dass
das auseinandergeht was fällt ihnen als
union ein
wir rufen jetzt nach dem start der staat
soll bezahlen soll ich ihn mal sagen was
die soziale marktwirtschaft unter ludwig
erhard darf mit vorgesehen hat ein
kartellamt dass das überprüft und
deswegen robert habeck vielen dank dass
sie das kartellamt gebeten habe dass die
überprüfung und nicht gleich dass wir da
steuergelder hinterher schicken und
übrigens
kann es mir nicht verkneifen irrenhaus
ihren vorgänger herr merz herrn
brinkhaus zu tier zu zitieren aus dem
aus dem sommer 20 21 da sagte er im
streit um steigende benzinpreise hat
unions fraktionschef
ralph brinkhaus angekündigt dass auch
mit der union an der spitze einer grund
künftigen bundesregierung benzin teurer
werden müsste meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren live brinkhaus am 11.06 hat
er das gesagt nachzulesen man reaktions
netzwerk deutschland meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren vielleicht
ist das der grund warum heute ehrlich
mehr hier ist sondern friedrich merz ich
glaube dass er sehr viel mehr recht hat
er das in der tat ich mich auch noch
erinnern kann auch aus ihren reihen das
ist forderung gab die co2 preis gar
nicht hoch genug zu schrauben das war
doch ihr punktes waren ihre ich kann
herrn jung ich kann herrn dobrindt
zitieren die das genau hier gefordert
haben wir haben das verhindert weil wir
immer die folgekosten für die menschen
im blick hatten meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und deswegen sage ich
ihnen hier handelt auch bei der
entlastung weil ich natürlich bei mir im
wahlkreis auch angesprochen werde von
den menschen und deswegen handeln wir
und wir schaffen was wir starten heute
den ersten schritt gehen heute abend um
das eeg die eeg-umlage abzuschaffen wir
haben den heizkostenzuschuss eingeführt
und er hätte noch mal verdoppeln wir
haben das vorziehen der pendlerpauschale
auf den weg gebracht die werbungskosten
erhöht wir handeln das sind insgesamt
mehr als 15 milliarden euro die in die
ampel koalition zur verfügung stellt um
menschen zu verlassen zu entlasten sehr
verehrten damen und herren und wir haben
gesagt bei bedarf werden wir noch
deutlich mehr machen das ist das was wir
ihnen zu sagen und frau präsidentin
lassen nämlich schließen
[Musik]
herr
bundesfinanzminister gesagt erneuerbaren
energien sind nicht nur freiheits
energien ja das ist richtig ich höre
ergänzen erneuerbaren energien sind auch
friedens energien dafür steht die ampel
dafür kämpfen wir wir hoffen viele war
ihnen von ihnen damit noch überzeugen zu
können und uns an ihrer seite zu haben
ihren antrag kann man natürlich nicht
zustimmen vielen dank sagt timon
gremmels von den sozialdemokraten zum
antrag der cdu csu fraktion der
grundlage dieser aussprache ist und er
hat es angesprochen das kartellamt
beobachte derzeit die preisentwicklung
bei benzin und diesel ganz genau und der
präsident der aufsichtsbehörde hat
gesagt wenn ihr obwohl sie jetzt wieder
die tankstellenpreise dem nicht folgen
oder sogar weiter steigen dann muss man
genau hinsehen
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen
wir befinden uns an einem wendepunkt
unserer geschichte schaffen wir es uns
von der abhängigkeit der fossilen zu
lösen oder finanzieren wir weiter putins
krieg und andere diktaturen und rasen
dabei ungebremst weiter in die
klimakatastrophe
faktes wir können es uns nicht leisten
zu versagen wir können ein fest hat
einen fossilen sei es öl gas oder kohle
nicht verantworten sondern wir müssen
alles dafür tun uns endlich zu befreien
eine energieversorgung aus erneuerbaren
schafft unabhängigkeit schafft
sicherheit schafft frieden
vor zwei jahren stand ich mit der
russischen umweltaktivistin alexandra
kaliber vor dem steinkohlekraftwerk
datteln 4 und gemeinsam haben wir
protestiert dagegen dass es ans netz
geht denn auch die steinkohle die dort
verbrannt wird kommt aus russland
alexander musste für ihr engagement
gegen steinkohleabbau in sibirien
fliehen zu uns dass putin menschenrechte
verletzt auch in den anbauregionen in
sibirien dass putin
gewissenlos in anderen ländern menschen
bombardiert wir seine kriegskasse füllen
das war auch schon lange bekannt
trotzdem wurde nichts gegen die
abhängigkeit unternommen das war falsch
auch da den vier hätte niemals ans netz
gehen dürfen
import von steinkohle einfach zu
entsetzt zu ersetzen jetzt zum beispiel
aus nordelbien oder aus südafrika das
ist die falsche lösung des problems
andere regionen auszuweiten massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen zuzulassen
gewalttätige konflikte und die
klimakrise weiter anzufeuern das darf
nicht länger die grundlage unseres
wohlstandes sein die lösung kann nur
sein die fossilen müssen im boden
bleiben und
zwar auch bei uns auch in meinem zuhause
und im rheinländischen braunkohlerevier
kolleginnen von der cdu wie könnt ihr es
wagen unsere dörfer felder und wälder
unwiederbringlich zerstören zu wollen
und gleichzeitig eiskalt 1000 meter
abstand für windenergieanlagen in
nordrhein-westfalen festzuhalten
dass bild auch wie das dorf literat am
tagebau garzweiler das akut bedroht ist
wie können sie es wagen aktuell ein
landwirt seine fruchtbaren felder seien
darauf für den abbau für die verbrennung
von braunkohle enteignen zu räumen wie
könnt ihr es zu wagen weiter bis 2038
kohle zu verbrennen und gleichzeitig
energieeinsparung wie beispielsweise ein
tempolimit auf autobahnen
dies abzulehnen
beantragten 1 ihr habt die dringlichkeit
der klimakrise nicht verstanden oder ihr
würdet in nordrhein-westfalen anders
handeln anders mit meinem zuhause
umgehen die zukunft gehört den
erneuerbaren und nicht in kohle baggern
unsere dörfer werden bleiben ob in
sibirien im rheinland oder in nordpol um
ihren danke
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege oder auf in der
weg für die fdp frau zu
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vielleicht sollte man in dieser
debatte auch einfach nochmal erwähnen
dass die ampel koalition genau 99 tage
gebraucht hat und die ersten
entlastungspaket für bürgerinnen und
bürger auf den weg zu bringen das hat
übrigens die alte regierung die in 16
jahren geschafft
und lassen sie uns einfach mal zum
antrag zurückkommen was fällt eigentlich
auf das ist eine sehr starke
aneinanderreihung von tollen und flotten
die ideen viele sind natürlich auch
schon in den leistungspaketen jetzt auf
den weg aber sei es drum geschenkt was
wichtig ist ist was fordern sie energie
und stromsteuer senken
fahrtkostenpauschale die jetzt gerade
geändert wird nochmal erhöhen weil ist
ehrlich genug
erholung von frist von freibeträgen
erhöhung von freibeträgen und natürlich
das liebgewonnene kind die umsatzsteuer
zu senken wobei sie eigentlich genau
wissen aus ihrer jahrelangen
regierungserfahrung das genau das erst
von der eu stattgegeben werden muss ein
gesetz verfahren verlangt und das kann
wochen oder auch monate dauern was diese
was diese ampel koalition
was diese ampel koalition auf jeden fall
nicht will ist ein antrag nach ihrem
stil wer will noch was wer hat noch
nicht weil das ist genau genau der punkt
den wir einfach verhindern wollen und
ich möchte mal eins noch zum schluss
sang zu ihrem antrag der sparen ganz
speziell zu ihren antrag alleine die 13
punkte unter punkt 3 wo sie ja mit den
ganzen entlastungsprogramm kommen und
den ganzen entlastungs forderungen
kommen also ich habe in der opposition
gelernt von meinem chef haushälter otto
fricke immer gesagt wenn ihr was fordert
dann müssen sie aber aufpassen weil das
muss auch alles seriös gegenfinanziert
sein und davon steht in ihrem antrag
aber überhaupt nichts gar nichts drin
das halte ich für unseriös
die ampel reagiert kurzfristig und
schnell und auf der anderen seite
brauchen langfristig kurzfristig und
schnell reagieren wir mit diesem
belastungspaket was jetzt gerade von
allen gesagt auf dem weg ist also ich
will man nur so sagen 8,8 cent für den
privaten haushalt das schon eine ganze
menge an eeg-umlage die wir sozusagen
jetzt mal gegen null fahren oder auf der
anderen seite finde ich auch dass ein
heizkostenzuschuss gerade für sozial
bedürftige menschen genau die richtige
antwort ist um das ganze wirklich besser
aus gestalten zu können für die menschen
langfristig da brauchen sie nur in den
koalitionsvertrag gucken da steht sehr
genau drin dass wir uns auch vorstellen
in dieser ganzen transformationsphase an
klima geld einzusetzen dieses klima geht
wird auch gerade entwickelt es kommt auf
den weg und ich kann ihnen sagen auch
dass wir dauerhaft dazu tragen die klima
wandelt die energiewende für die
menschen erträglicher zu machen und noch
mal ein punkt zudem
läge hier
schaffen sie müssen jetzt einen punkt
setzen verlieren wir uns nicht in der
bloßen formulierung von zielen wir
setzen die notwendigen maßnahmen
konsequent um eine person sicherheit und
bezahlbarkeit aus den augen zu verlieren
das zeigt respekt vor den bürgerinnen
und bürgern von den unternehmen in
diesem land genauso wie sie die
kommenden generationen wie das geht
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat der kollege
ulrich lange das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ja
der vormittag hat begonnen mit einer
rede die uns noch mal deutlich vor augen
geführt hat dass wir uns in einer
zeitenwende befinden und eine
zeitenwende hat mehrere aspekte sie hat
langfrist aspekte und sehr kurzfristig
pacte und in dieser debatte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen geht es um
langfrist aspekte das ist natürlich das
jahr zu den erneuerbaren aber für alle
die die über 10 h in dem zusammenhang
reden sei mal gesagt schaut sich das mal
genauer an bei ihren platz drei bei den
erneuerbaren ich würde mal auf wasser pv
biomasse und so weiter auch schon so
einfach und billig liebe kollegen der
spd wir haben dass er jetzt zwölf jahre
zusammen gemacht ist es nicht und für
die kollegen der fdp noch mal einen
kleinen hinweis auch zur erinnerung für
die gasspeicher
zuständig war der kollege
ex-kollege staatssekretär homann von
philipp rösler also lieber kollege bruce
bevor sie hier auf andere werfen schauen
sie sich bitte an wie die sachen konkret
gelaufen sind damals gelang mehr nein
wir reden wir reden heute über die
menschen wir reden darüber dass man
jetzt für die menschen handeln muss und
genau das beinhaltet unser antrag es
geht um sicherheit und es geht um
bezahlbare kite und da gibt es eben
darum jeden handlungsspielraum
kurzfristigen und langfristigen
handlungsspielraum zu nutzen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
die menschen haben angst
die menschen haben sorgen um ihre
existenz um ihr leben um ihr wohnen um
ihr fahren um ihre wirtschaft die
logistik prof hat sorgen bei dem
spritpreis wer über pnv redet der muss
auch darüber reden dass die busse im
ländlichen raum von unseren familien
betriebenen busunternehmen auch nicht
mit luft sondern in der regel mit diesel
fahren und genau um diese dinge müssen
wir uns kümmern und genau das ist
natürlich mit das worum es uns in
unserem antrag gibt und wenn sie die
pendlerpauschale nennen naja die ersten
21 kilometer bieten sie sich ja nicht
sondern auch die müssen gefahren werden
und da vergessen sie auch wieder die
menschen auf dem land und wenn sie beim
heizkostenzuschuss sagen denn haben sie
verdoppelt ja richtig sie haben ihn für
gewisse gruppen ein oder werden in für
gewisse gruppen einführen aber wo bleibt
denn der normalverdiener wo bleibt denn
die familie in ihrem reihenhaus in ihrem
einfamilienhaus unter umständen mit den
zwei einkommen mit den zwei
durchschnittlichen einkommen die jetzt
hunderte von euro mehr für energie
zahlen müssen die bedienen sie nicht
aber die zahlen und es kann nicht sein
dass wir profitieren als staat zu kosten
auf kosten und zu lasten dieser menschen
und deswegen unsere vorschläge liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir wollen mehr als einen tank rabatt
und da muss ich wirklich lachen ich kann
mich an die diskussion erinnern wie es
unpassend box ging jetzt machen wir dank
seines ich kann mich erinnern über
tankgutscheine in meiner kindheit wenn
man nach italien gefahren ist für alle
die die von ein bisschen älter sind die
senkung der mehrwertsteuer ist natürlich
eine möglichkeit natürlich gibt es
europarechtliche hürden aber lieber
kollegen ein die polen machen es geht
man kann nicht immer nur sagen es geht
nicht es geht nicht es geht nicht in
einer krise ich kann mich doch nicht nur
immer auf diesen punkt zurückziehen und
gleiches bei der reduzierung der
energiesteuern auch diese können sie
reduzieren auf das europäische
mindestmaß tun sie's handeln sie
profitieren sie nicht als star auf dem
rücken der menschen das ist unseriös
wir
haben diesen antrag genau deswegen
gemacht weil wir auch auf den bus warten
in der letzten krise hat hier mal jemand
einen bums versprochen inzwischen
schweigt mister wumms aber genau das
müssen wir machen genau das müssen wir
machen wenn wir den menschen helfen
wollen
wir erleben eine preisspirale bei der
energie diese müssen wir durchbrechen
und das geht nicht mit kosmetischen
korrekturen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
funktioniert nur mit einer vollbremsung
und genau dafür sind unsere vorschläge
kurzfristig handeln für die menschen und
langfristige perspektiven für die
sicherheit der energie unsere vorschläge
liegen auf dem tisch ich kann nur sagen
packen sie es mit an die energiewende ja
aber nicht über nacht die menschen die
menschen brauchen jetzt eine lösung die
menschen brauchen jetzt eine perspektive
die menschen brauchen jetzt die
sicherheit für ihr leben für ihr wohnen
und das ist mit wesentlich ihre
verantwortung dankeschön ulrich lange
der fraktions vize der unionsfraktion
ja in der bundesregierung nicht
abgestimmt aber bundesfinanzminister
lindner hat seine überlegungen für eine
direkte entlastung von autofahrern beim
tanken von diesel und benzin präzisiert
er könnte sich vorstellen beispielsweise
einen staatlichen zuschuss von 40 cent
pro liter für drei monate befristet
ausgezahlt
zu seiner ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag hat nun der kollege robin
maison rouge das wort für die spd
fraktion
ja aus der spd fraktion kommt da sehen
wir schon sitzt im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
damen und herren ich bin in einem
kleinen dorf aufgewachsen lang endlich
das einzige brauchbare verkehrsmittel
dort ist das auto wir fahren auto wenn
der liter benzin 1 60 kostet und wir
fahren auto wenn der liter benzin 230
kostet denn wir kommen nur so von a nach
b aber wenn das benzin 230 kostet kommen
einige von uns nicht nur von a nach b
einige von uns kommen dann auch in
schwierigkeiten weil vieles gerade
teurer wird die gasrechnung für eine
durchschnittliche familie in einem
unsanierten haus die wird dieses jahr
voraussichtlich und 2000 euro steigen
die familien die hier finanziell ihre
grenzen überschreiten leben nicht nur in
langenenslingen sie leben überall in
unserem eigentlich reichen land
was sagen wir diesen familien wir können
es machen die cdu und csu heute
vorschlagen wir können versuchen der
neuen bundesregierung alles sind alle
schuld in die schuhe zu schieben und wir
können diverse sofortmaßnahmen aufzählen
mit dem wir angeblich jahrzehntealte
probleme lösen und wir können zornig wie
lange die tatsachen
oder wir sagen diesen familien die
wahrheit wir sagen ihnen wir stecken
gerade in mehreren tiefen krisen diese
krisen sind so tief dass wir zeit
brauchen werden sie zu lösen bis dahin
werden wir versuchen die schlimmsten
risiken von allen fern zu halten
aber das wird hart besonders für die die
wenig geld haben die krise ist nämlich
nicht dass unser benzin 230 kostet die
krise ist dass fünf mineralölkonzerne
gerade den benzinpreis künstlich
hochhalten
auf der auch der staat hat seinen anteil
am preis über steuern und abgaben
natürlich aber wenn wir diesen anteil
senken erhöhen wir damit vor allem die
gewinne für diese fünf mineralölkonzerne
und 83 millionen deutsche bezahlen dann
weiter wucherpreis an der tankstelle die
krise ist nicht dass die gasrechnung
dieses jahr hoch werden die krise ist
dass wir ein viertel unserer energie aus
erdgas gewinnen und dass die hälfte
dieses erdgases aus russland kommt und
dass wir diese mengen nicht aus anderen
quellen ganz ersetzen werden können die
krise ist auch nicht dass die
strompreise steigen die krise ist dass
wir eine für uns schlechte art gewählt
haben strom zu gewinnen zu verteilen
denn wir produzieren
treibhausgase die unseren planeten
zerstören und wir zahlen meistens großen
energiekonzerne irgendwo in deutschland
viel geld anstatt unseren strom mit
erneuerbaren energien vor unseren
haustüren zu gewinnen wo wir die preise
stärker selbst kontrollieren können die
krise sind nicht die steigenden kosten
steigende kosten sind symptome für viele
sind diese symptome schmerzhaft und
darum finde ich es richtig dass die
bundesregierung diese symptome bekämpft
mit einem noch mal hören
heizkostenzuschuss dadurch dass wir die
eeg-umlage abschaffen durch ein gas
speichergesetz und mit vielem mehr
trotzdem müssen wir einiges
grundsätzlich verändern und das wird
zeit kosten
liebe unionsfraktion sie hatten 16 jahre
zeit sie hatten 16 jahre lang das
kanzleramt um deutschland zu verändern
dass es mehr als die hälfte meines
lebens so zu tun als seien die
erleuchtung wie das jetzt doch geht
ausgerechnet in der opposition gekommen
dass es unehrlich und es ist nicht nur
unehrlich den eindruck zu erwecken wir
könnten einige der größten
herausforderungen unserer zeit jetzt
schnell mit einigen maßnahmen lösen das
ist sogar gefährlich rechts von ihnen
sitzen nur noch die die sich von
enttäuschung wut und hass füttern sie
sie nicht helfen sie lieber uns die
probleme bei der wurzel zu packen der
schlüssel sind anständige löhne und
erneuerbare energien überall haben sie
vielen dank
der kommissar aus kaders für die ist die
fraktion seien erste regel hier im
parlament er ist gewählt über die
landesliste baden württemberg und man
weit raus ist sie zollernalb sigmaringen
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat die kollegin lisa bott um das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir reden viel darüber wie naiv
wir gegenüber russland war und jetzt
waren wir in einem angriffskrieg auf und
reiben uns die augen wir sind von
fossilen energien abhängig wie konnte
das passieren
wir waren nicht naiv meine damen und
herren die wendigen rand
unsere klimabilanz unserer hohen co2
emissionen sind das protokoll diese
ignoranz alles kein zufall
es wurden lieber veraltete standards im
bau- und immerzu gefördert als
wärmepumpe und effizienz lieber
straßenbau als radwege und bahnstrecken
lauter politische entscheidungen gegen
den klimaschutz stecken dahinter und
erst jetzt wird vielen bewusst dass es
die maschen entscheidungen gegen unsere
eigene sicherheit waren darin muss jetzt
schluss sein
ja klimapolitik ist sicherheitspolitik
war das ist sie nicht nur in
sonntagsreden sondern das ist sie auch
im detail und lieber herr lange wie bei
csu und cdu die diskussion über
windkraft abstände in bayern ist eine
diskussion über energie souveränität
frage von planungs beschleunigung ist
wichtig die frage dass wir unsere
windkraft produktion in europa halten
dass sie nicht abwandert die
solar-branche das ist jetzt wichtig und
im übrigen das verlangt schon einiges an
co2 als partei der haupt mit blockade
ministerpräsidenten antrag zu schreiben
unter dem zu fordern dass mehr flächen
für
erneuerbare energien bereitgestellt
werden das kann ja nur als appell an
ihre eigenen leute gemeint sein und das
ist richtig dass es gut denn wenn wir es
ernst meinen mit der freiheit europas
mit dem ende der ignoranz dann gilt es
die ergriffenheit die wir heute morgen
bei der rede von präsident zur ems knie
verspürt zu haben umzusetzen
inkonsequente energiepolitik und genau
das werden wir tun und es ja wir haben
damals in
riesa button war dass sich die grünen
und wir haben es in einem letzten redner
zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt und er
kommt aus den reihen der
sozialdemokraten das wird er ab
er sitzt im
wirtschaftsausschuss des bundestages
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren wir führen hier die
debatte in dem eindruck eines
völkerrechts eines zivilisationsbruch
von vladimir putin und wir haben die
aufgabe auch wenn wir unter diesem oder
gerade weil wir unter diesem eindruck
stehen hier mit einer klaren
verantwortung zu reden und zu handeln
und das ist eben auch unsere aufgabe
denn wir müssen doch sehen und das geht
in aller klarheit in die richtung der
unionsfraktion wir die reden und handeln
sind doch mitverantwortlich für
teilweise die spekulationen die den
preis in die höhe treiben denn wir sehen
doch in den letzten tagen das eben genau
der rohölpreis und der preis an den
tankstellen eklatant auseinander
gelaufen ist das ist das ergebnis von
spekulation nicht das ergebnis von
knappheit meine damen und herren und
deswegen
und deswegen sind ja auch vorschläge wie
die sie machen mit steuersenkungen
darauf zu reagieren doch am ende nichts
weiteres als eine subvention der gewinne
auf spekulationen der mineralölkonzern
und das meine damen und herren kann doch
in der tat nicht unser ernst sein als
antwort auf die hohe belastung
die hohe belastung ist doch realität für
den auszubildenden der in vielen unserer
wahlkreise auf das auto angewiesen ist
weil er wie bei mir vielleicht von max
haller grasleben zur ausbildungsstätte
fahren muss es ist eben realität bis in
die mitte der einkommen hinein dass die
belastungen für kraftstoffe und für das
heizen extrem angestiegen sind und weil
es doch so ist es ist unsere aufgabe
eben nicht mit blankem populismus darauf
zu reagieren sondern mit einer klaren
und zielgerichteten maßnahmen paket was
erstens sozial ausgewogen ausgerichtetes
meine damen und herren was zweites ziel
gerichtet ist und eben bei denjenigen
ankommt die belastung haben und was
drittens am ende auch unserer
gesamtverantwortung
dafür gerecht wird wer eigentlich an
dieser preistreiberei jede verantwortung
trägt und weil das so ist ist nämlich
neben dieser großen frage der belastung
für verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
auch eine große herausforderung und
aufgabe für uns dafür zu sorgen und
schickte unternehmen die in dieser
herausforderung gerade mit enorm hohen
preisen konfrontiert sind genau auch für
diese unternehmen hier eine entlastung
herbei zu führen muss gestatten sie eine
frage oder bemerkung aus der fdp
fraktion ihr das tut mir wirklich nicht
not und hilft uns in der sache auch
nicht weiter also wir haben die aufgabe
für unternehmen hier eine entlastung
herbei zu führen
nur weil sie sich in ihrem eigenen
populismus sonnen wollen bleiben sind
die man da sitzen wenn die hin wenn
diese debatte ihre intelligenz
übersteigt dann tut mir
kollege muss ich habe die uhr angehalten
ich bitte
darum auch bei zwischenrufen den mund
nasenschutz
entsprechend zu tragen so
beim nächsten regelverstoß bald ich mir
die entsprechenden ordnungsmaßnahmen vor
so sie haben wieder das wort vielen dank
frau präsidentin ich sitze noch mal an
mit dem zweiten teil der jetzt genau
wichtig ist nämlich die unternehmen in
unserem land zu entlasten wir haben die
große aufgabe sowohl für diejenigen im
logistikbereich zum beispiel die unter
enorm hohen kraftstoffkosten leiden und
am ende auch die kosten bis zum
verbraucher weitergegeben werden wir
haben die aufgabe für die
energieintensiven unternehmen
es sind beispielsweise vorhin die auch
die glashütte in bayern schon
angesprochen worden dass wir genau auch
dort für eine entlastung sorgen aber
eben nicht indem wir jetzt will die
subventionspolitik betreiben sondern
indem wir systematisch dafür sorgen dass
der preis nach unten geben meine damen
und herren das ist doch unsere kluge
verantwortung der wir gerecht werden
müssen in dieser besonderen
ausnahmesituation und wir wissen das
natürlich auch diese maßnahmen an vielen
stellen europäisch abgestimmt werden
müsste es jetzt unsere aufgabe eine
brücke für diese unternehmen zu bauen
damit sie eben mit der liquidität über
die runden kommen damit in ihre
existenzen und die arbeitsplätze nicht
gefordert nicht gefährdet sind meine
damen und herren und ersparen ich gebe
ihnen mit einem punkt aus ihrer rede
ganz ausdrücklich recht sie haben als
cdu csu nicht die verantwortung zur
regierungsbildung bekommen sondern wir
als ampel und ich füge hinzu das ist gut
so ihren antrag lehnen wir ab vielen
herzlichen dank
zwei common sense von der spd fraktion
ihren letzter redner und jetzt kommen
wir zur abstimmung die aussprache wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion der cdu/csu auf drucksache
1016 mit dem titel für eine sichere
bezahlbare und souveräne
energieversorgung die fraktion der
cdu/csu hat namentliche abstimmung
verlangt die abstimmung erfolgt in der
west lobby sie haben zur abgabe ihrer
stimme nach eröffnung der abstimmung
20 minuten zeit
bitte gehen sie nicht alle gleichzeitig
zur abstimmung
ich bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer die plätze einzunehmen
ich sehe das ist der fall ich eröffne
die namentliche abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion der cdu/csu
die abstimmungs ohne werden um 13 uhr
wir schauen mal raus in die west lobby
des reichstages nach wie vor wenn
amtlich abstimmung verlangt ist werden
hier die urne jedem flur aufgestellt und
für 20 minuten offen gelassen das ganze
hat natürlich
sind das länger zeit ist dass corinna
abstände eingehalten werden können und
das ist nicht wie sonst im bundestag zu
einer sozusagen wallung geben würde
dass sich hier alle gleichzeitig die und
versammeln